foreign
this Saturday night Russia ramps up
attacks in Ukraine private homes and
buildings burned down while Russia still
claims it's not targeting civilians and
Germany prepares for a possible Russian
blockade to a key gas pipeline New York
takes gun control laws into its own
hands after the Supreme Court ruling six
relatively young Supreme Court Justices
who feel incredibly emboldened and they
are not stopping with this the
controversial case is the conservative
Court plans to tackle next a dramatic
rescue and dozens missing in the South
China Sea the typhoon that caused this
ship to split into
[Music]
name may not ring a bell but her Legacy
is Unforgettable remembering a woman who
used humor to raise awareness for a
disease no one wants to talk about
global national with Farah Nasser
good evening to you and thank you for
joining us we begin in Ukraine where
Russia is escalating its assaults on the
city of lissachenks it's an all-out
attempt to seize the last stronghold of
resistance in eastern Ukraine's luhansk
Province Ukrainian Fighters have spent
weeks trying to defend the city Russian
forces claim they have completely
encircled it but Ukraine denies that
Melissa Changs has become the new focus
of fighting after its Twin City severe
doniesque was reduced to Rubble last
week
Russia continues to deny that it's
targeting Sega villions while it fires
at cities in the north and in the South
and it has been a deadly week there
missiles slammed into an apartment Block
in a shopping mall killing dozens of
citizens today Ukrainian president
vlodimir zielinski called the kremlin's
war strategy deliberately targeted
Russian Terror David Aiken has our top
story tonight
debris destruction a Survivor is rescued
but this is not the front line in the
Ukraine Russia War it is a residential
neighborhood a hundred kilometers behind
the front lines Ukrainian authorities
say there are no military targets here
and yet it was targeted by Russian
Munitions it is hardly the only example
in the last week of what Kiev says are
intensified missile attacks on cities
far from the main Battlefield that
deliberately targets civilian sites
on Friday a missile struck an apartment
Block near the southern port city of
Odessa authorities say at least 21 were
killed these apartment buildings and
homes are 50 kilometers Southwest of
Odessa far away from the fighting and on
Monday Russian missiles hit a shopping
mall in the central Ukraine city of
cremenchuk killing at least 19.
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
on Saturday accused Russia of
deliberately trying to kill Ukrainian
civilians
this is conscious deliberately targeted
Russian Terror zielinski said and not
some sort of Heir or a coincidental
missile strike the targeting of
civilians comes as NATO countries
including Canada vowed Thursday to take
a tougher stand against Russian
aggression and agreed to invite Finland
and Sweden to join the military Alliance
we all know that Russia's illegal
unjustifiable and horrific invasion of
Ukraine requires us all to stand
together but Vladimir Putin hardly seems
deterred and waved aside the West's
concerns a Kremlin spokesperson said
quote Russian Armed Forces do not work
with civilian targets and yet the
governor of the Ukrainian province of
luhansk said Saturday the Russian
strategy is clear private houses in
attacked Villages are burning down one
by one David Aiken Global News
and there is concern in Germany that
Russia may cut off its natural gas
supplies
Germans are being urged to save energy
and prepare for a difficult winter the
head of Germany's regulatory Agency for
energy says residents should have their
gas spoilers and radiators checked and
adjusted for maximum efficiency in June
Russia significantly reduced gas flows
to European customers EU countries are
still scrambling to refill power storage
facilities
New York lawmakers have approved a
sweeping overhaul of the state's handgun
licensing rules in response to last
month's Landmark Supreme Court ruling
which struck down previous restrictions
Jennifer Johnson looks at what the new
rules mean for New Yorkers and how the
state's Governor is vowing to fight back
against other controversial decisions
made by America's highest court
New York lawmakers feel the new mostly
conservative U.S Supreme Court went too
far when it struck down its state law
requiring proof of self-defense to
obtain a concealed carry gun permit
the court in its ruling said all gun
regulations must have historic routes
New York leaders are firing back the
Supreme Court's decisions for certainly
setbacks but we view them as only
temporary setbacks and I refuse to
surrender my right as Governor to
protect New Yorkers from gun violence in
what was called an extraordinary
legislative session Friday lawmakers
took Swift Action Now requiring private
businesses that allow concealed guns to
post that publicly so everyone using
that business knows gun buyers will have
to provide the state their social media
accounts and character references and
background checks just got a lot harder
New York will now requiring conduct
background checks for all ammunition
purchases and comparing ammunition
records against records of other
databases you know which identify civil
convicted of felonies action was also
taken to ban concealed weapons from
so-called sensitive areas including
Times Square Subways bus and train
stations shootings in New York City have
more than doubled this year compared to
2019. this week a young mother was shot
in the head at point-blank range by an
ex-boyfriend while pushing a stroller in
the city the Supreme Court really made
America a very dangerous place
particularly in New York City I just
don't know what they were thinking New
York lawmakers will also take action to
ensure a woman's right to abortion in
their state that comes after the high
Court's most dramatic decision this
session when it not only upheld
Mississippi's law Banning abortions
after 15 weeks but then overturned the
constitutional right to abortion there
are six relatively young Supreme Court
Justices who feel incredibly emboldened
incredibly aggressive to move American
law to the right and they are not
stopping with this
a new Yahoo news poll shows more than 60
percent of Americans now have no
confidence in the high court with more
controversial cases coming up this fall
including ending affirmative action in
college admissions and allowing
businesses the right to refuse services
for same-sex weddings
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
to travel next and while frustrating
lines and delays I mean irritating
Canadian passengers for weeks the travel
chaos is also happening at airports
right across the United States and
especially this holiday weekend long
lines delays and canceled flights have
plagued thousands of Travelers ahead of
July 4th United American and Delta
Airlines are all trimming their
schedules to deal with a staffing
shortage this week Delta reportedly
offered eight passengers ten thousand
dollars to give up their seats on an
oversold flight
Cruise in Ottawa were cleaning up today
following the first in-person Canada Day
celebrations in two years the event was
once feared to be another protest-filled
day in the nation's capital but things
turned out to be relatively calm with
the help of a major police presence on
the ground a presence that came with a
big price tag Kyle Benning reports
at the start of the week the Ottawa
Police Service and the city said it
would be ready for any situation on
Canada Day and with all those extra
hands on deck now the issue is how that
bill will be paid
hundreds of officers were brought into
the city to maintain Public Safety and
ensure protesters didn't break laws or
bylaws protest crowds were in the
hundreds on Friday by Saturday those
numbers had dwindled but extra boots on
the ground to handle the potential
crowds still come at a cost this is way
over our budget Eli al-shantiri the
chairperson for the city's police board
says the policing model in place is
unsustainable and they will be placing
funding requests with the federal and
provincial governments the feds already
committed to tackling the 35 million
dollar policing bill from the Winter's
so-called Freedom Convoy but law
enforcement costs stemming from this
weekend and the approximate three
million ruling Thunder Convoy haven't
been covered yet and I'm hoping that we
both step up to the plate we still have
not submit the final bill we said we
will wait till July 6th
One Security researcher says other
levels of government footing the bill is
one solution but there is another the
other option is of course to realize
that probably the Ottawa Police Service
is not the best position to be policing
National protests in the capital
that means putting either the Ontario
Provincial Police or RCMP in charge of
securing protests in the capital in the
future but whether that shift happens
before the next organized protest is
anyone's guess pharah
Kyle Benning and Ottawa thank you Kyle
the federal government is changing how
companies add nutrition warnings to food
products the new requirements will take
effect in 2026 and include warning
symbols on the front of pre-packaged
food rather than on the back for foods
with high levels of saturated fat sugar
or sodium but as Ross Lord reports one
notable food product that was under
consideration is now being given an
exemption
the government says changing the way
food packaging looks will change how
consumers eat research shows that these
simple clear symbol on the front of food
packages will help consumers choose
foods lower in saturated fat sugars and
or sodium Health Canada says the new
labels will be mandatory by January of
2026 it expects the food industry to
start phasing them in before then to
some Public Health Advocates the move is
an obvious way to encourage Canadians to
eat healthier foods and for
manufacturers to make healthier products
there are complications the government
decided to exempt ground beef from the
new labeling after protests by the beef
industry some food researchers say the
exemption is understandable going back
to the spirit of the policy if you're
enticing the the industry to come up
with healthier products how do you do
that with a single ingredient product
it's impossible Sylvan charlapose is
stronger labeling does make a difference
as shown by the government campaign
against trans fats they're just
basically Force the industry to label
the presence of trans fats so it really
forced the industry to get rid of them
uh essentially others are reacting a bit
more cautiously food labels being the
the end-all to everyone
doing their dietary lifestyle I just
don't see that that's going to be the
case I personally do believe though that
that the sugary products are the ones
that we really should be watching out
for more often than the others but it's
all definitely important and I think
it's a good step in the right direction
putting nutritional warnings front and
center in the ongoing effort to promote
healthy eating Ross Lord Global News
pharmaceutical firm Purdue Pharma Canada
has agreed to have proposed 150 million
dollar settlement in a class action
lawsuit over its role in Canada's opioid
epidemic the historic settlement is part
of a bc-led lawsuit that aims to recover
health care costs for what it calls the
wrongful conduct of opioid makers and
Distributors it's being called an
important step in this country's toxic
drug crisis but harm reduction Advocates
say the sum is inconsequential Aaron
McArthur has more
the deaths are staggering
since 2016 opioids responsible for more
than 27 000 lost lives across the
country
while illegal narcotics have taken much
of the blame prescription medication has
played a role in this Health crisis BC's
attorney general announcing an historic
settlement with one of the
pharmaceutical companies responsible I
can announce that we reached a 150
million dollar settlement with Purdue
Pharma Canada
the settlement has yet to be approved by
the courts and the provincial and
territorial governments still have to
determine where that money will be
divided
the BC government has promised to use
its portion directly on related Health
Care Services we know the settlement
will not make up for the lives lost the
terrible loss of loved ones in our
communities so our government remains
steadfast in its commitment to end the
public health emergency the BC
government launched the class action
suit in the fall of 2018 against dozens
of Manufacturers Distributors and
consultants for opioid products
at the time the initial number thrown
around was in the tens of billions of
dollars in health care costs critics
argue settling now for 150 million seems
more symbolic than anything else
150 million it's it's really a drop in
the bucket
um it'll be interesting to see where the
province puts this money
um I'll be pushing definitely for the
implementation of of a wide spread and
low barrier regulated Supply
give settlements with other companies
can't be reached a hearing to certify
the class action suit will be heard in
Aaron MacArthur Global News
tragedy in this
frightening moment
scrambled
this dramatic footage shows a desperate
rescue underway in the South China Sea
and Industrial support ship broke in two
during a typhoon and sunk about 300
kilometers south of Hong Kong more than
two dozen crew members are still
unaccounted for authorities dispatched
planes and helicopters to help with the
rescue at least three people from the
crew of 30 have been brought to safety
Rescuers are increasing the search area
and extending operations Into the Night
Iranian State media says at least five
people have been killed and more than 50
others injured after a series of
powerful earthquakes rocked the southern
province of hormozgan overnight
video shows large parts of an entire
Village near Iran's Gulf Coast flattened
following the nighttime Quakes officials
say the initial earthquake of magnitude
6.1 was followed by dozens of
aftershocks including two that
registered at magnitudes over six search
and rescue operations are said to be
coming to an end with efforts now to
clean up
no more x-rays the radiation-free
Canadian Imaging Innovation that could
change your future visits to the dentist
you're watching global national
this is incredible researchers in
Alberta have invented new technology
that could change the face of Dentistry
it's a new way to map out the mouth
allowing dentists and orthodontists a
safer way to assess diagnose and treat
their patients Sue lingo reports
when an orthodontist realigns a
patient's teeth they need to figure out
how far they can safely move them within
the bone structure of the mouth so
currently we actually don't have a way
of knowing that so I just take my best
guess clinically the U of A's Dr Paul
major says he's long-known ultrasound
would be helpful but the standard probe
won't fit in a mouth so he teamed up
with U of A Radiology expert Dr Lawrence
Lee to create a solution this is the
part that would go inside the mouth up
in here their toothbrush sized intraoral
ultrasound device provides a
two-dimensional view of the inner
structures it can be turned to various
angles and has a special pad to contain
the ultrasound gel which can't be
swallowed it has to be durable and also
conform to the you know shape of the of
the teeth and also has to be tough
because sometimes you got very sharp
edges there right now they're taking the
technology further with an expanded view
the two images has a very limited Field
view that's all you can see you have one
slice that's what you can see you can't
see the surrounding the new 3D device
could replace some of the work of this
large 3D imaging tool which uses x-rays
exposing patients to radiation
ultrasound does not involve radiation
making it especially safe for kids so I
could do this on every child I could do
it multiple times on every child
throughout treatment so I can look at
the progression as I go along artificial
intelligence would help make the device
user-friendly for dentists who are not
trained in Radiology the technology
could eventually be used to pinpoint gum
disease and Cavities as well as guide
dental implant design ultimately
changing Dentistry for good the goal is
that the dentist can provide better care
to the patients in their office
lingo Global News
next
about a woman who smashed the stigma
surrounding bowel cancer
foreign
ERS crowded the Streets of London today
to celebrate the 50th anniversary of the
UK's first Pride Parade it's being
called the biggest ever turnout for the
event with the mayor's office saying
that over a million people were in
attendance that's in stark contrast to
the inaugural March in 1972 which is
said to have involved a couple of
thousand people
a Fierce and fun advocate for early
cancer detection lost her own battle
with the disease this week Dame Deborah
James used her experience and her
platform to help others now her online
presence wasn't always pretty but her
posts were honest and meant to get
people to learn how to spot the disease
that cut her life short Europe bureau
chief Christopher mansing has more on
her life-saving message
[Music]
she was known as the bowel babe it was
with her spirited personality and Frank
talk that named Deborah James touched
people around the world stripping away
the stigma of bowel cancer maybe not the
house she joked raised millions and
brought awareness to a disease people
just don't like talking about
diagnosed with incurable cancer in 2016
she made every moment count advocating
tirelessly for research and awareness in
May she was given a Dame Hood in
recognition of that work her passing on
the 28th of June was met by an
outpouring of sympathies Prince William
the Duke of Cambridge wrote We are so
sad to hear the heartbreaking news about
Dame Deborah our thoughts are with her
children her family and her loved ones
Deborah was an inspirational and
unfalteringly brave woman whose Legacy
will live on vowel or colorectal cancer
as it's known in Canada is one of the
top five cancers diagnosed not only here
in the UK but back in Canada as well
because of the pandemic a lot of people
have not been screened in a timely
manner and we're starting to see a lot
more advanced cancers which are much
more difficult to treat still Barry
Stein uses the Mantra preventable
treatable and beatable
screening in Canada starts at age 50.
but if you have a family history or a
genetic predisposition you need to test
early and often it's an easy decision to
make to get screened especially starting
with a fit test which you do at home
it's a simple past non-invasive when
screening and surgery is delayed
mortality rates increase for every month
surgery is put off Stein says mortality
bumps up by 10 percent a healthy diet
and exercise can help but knowing the
symptoms is critical Dame Deborah often
share those while getting treatments
advocating with a seemingly bottomless
reserve of strength and Care the bowel
Bape was 40 and in the last countless
lives but her attitude is also a lesson
for all of us that's global national for
this Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser and
I want to thank you on behalf of our
crew for spending your evening with us
tonight's your Canada is near bread
Creek Alberta we love senior Canada so
please keep emailing us those photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
until I see you tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other good night
[Music]